[Musique]
tu sais Clark un VPN est un système
permettant de créer un lien direct entre
des ordinateurs distants qui isolent
leur échange du reste du
[Musique]
trafic cl cette vidéo est
sponsoriser tu les feras surfer en toute
tranquillité Clark grâce à toi ils
pourront même aller dans des pays
étrangers et contourner les
fireewall tu utiliseras le code joueur
et tu leur donnera un abonnement de 3
ans avec 81 % de réduction ainsi que
deux cadeaux incroyables 4 mois
supplémentaires gratuits et
l'application de gestion de mot de passe
nor
pass
[Musique]
Clark tu m'as écouté
Clark 1 2 3
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
4 salut à tous nouvel sujet et
aujourd'hui nous allons repartir dans
les années 90 et je vais vous parler de
quelque chose qui était colossal sal
c'était inévitable si vous avez vécu ne
serait-ce qu'un jour dans les années 90
vous avez forcément dû tomber dessus au
moins une fois par hasard je parle
évidemment des séries AB Production si
le matin le club de roté appartenait au
dessin animé l'après-midi était dominé
par les séries AB on y va oui Salut les
Musclés Salut les Musclés premier baiser
le miel et les abeilles les anéphaaces
les ané bleus les filles d'à côté la
philo selon Philippe et j' n'ai même pas
cité le tiers et surtout j'ai oublié la
série la plus connue je parle évidemment
de Hélène et les garçons une
fille ça le cœur tout rempli de
chansons qui refleurissent à toutes les
saison pour
l'amour d'un garçon ah bordel pourquoi
je connais ce truc alors que je
détestais ça non parce que quand tu
étais un garçon dans les années 90 ces
séries ça voulait dire une chose ça
piquait la place d'un épisode de DBZ
bordel mais aujourd'hui on va quand même
faire un effort et se replonger dedans
et tout d'abord commençons par l'origine
de tout notre histoire commence par une
hépatite oui je sais il y a pas beaucoup
d'histoires qui commencent par une
hépatite mais là c'est vrai on va
essayer de démarrer un peu avant alors
notre histoire commence à la fin des
années 70 lorsque Jean-Luc azoulet le
producteur de tout ce qui concerne de
près ou de loin le club de rôé et de
tout AB Production en général donc
littéralement le Dieu de TF1 pendant les
années 90 mange une pizza au moule dans
un restaurant sans savoir que la dit
moule était avarié il attrape alors une
ép viral et doit rester immobilisé
pendant 40 jours dans son lit ce qui lui
donne l'occasion de glandouiller devant
la télé et de découvrir dorotthé et ses
amis sur Antin 2 présenté par une jeunne
présentatrice du nom de Dorothé qu'il
décide alors de débaucher pour la faire
venir sur TF1 et créer le club doroté et
tout ce qui va avec alors je sais ce que
vous vous dites hein une pizza au moule
mais bon la vraie question c'est pas ça
c'est comment une moule a pu attraper
une hépatite et bien tout commença dans
l'océan Atlantique lorsque Michel la
moule je pense qu'on a les informations
principales on peut continuer bon après
c'est ironique he parce que l'hépatite A
c'est un truc qu'on a att trpe en
mangeant des matières fécales notamment
donc on peut remercier le cuisinier
d'avoir chié dans la pizza au moules de
Jean-Luc sans ça on aurait pas eu Dragon
Ball Z euh de
rien alors déjà commençons par poser
l'histoire parce que sachez que les
séries AB Production comme pour Marvel
ou mondow World sont des univers
connecté il s'agit donc d'un cinématique
Universe la première série est donc
salul musclé sortie en 1989 et sa suite
la croisière F amour bien plus tard en
1995 salut musclé met en scène le
personnage de franoisier et dans la
série apparî rapidement Justine sè qui
aura droit en 1991 à sa propre série
premier baiser une série qui aura
plusieurs suites d'abord les années fac
en 95 puis les années bleuses en 98 en
apprendant cette série que Justine
possède deux sœurs une première du nom
de Chloé Girard qui n'apparaît qu'en béé
mais qui reviendra bien plus tard dans
la série Les Mystères de l'amour mais
surtout une autre sœur Hélène la plus
connu qui 1 an après premier baiser en
1992 aura elle aussi sa propre série
hélè et les garçons qui aura également
des suites sous le nom du miracle de
l'amour en 1995 les vacances de l'amour
en 96 et enfin la plus récente en 2011
Les Mystères de l'amour et c'est bon
tout le monde suit bref Girard le père
d'élène et Justine est donc demi- frère
de framboisier à une sœur Anette Girard
personnage féminin principal de la série
les garçons de la plage en 1994 un frère
théodul qui est le père de Sophie Girard
qui apparaît dans la philo selon
Philippe en 95 et Débora Girard qui
apparaît dans premier baiser avec sa
cousine Justine la mère de Justine
Hélène et Chloé Marie Girard de son nom
de jeune fille Marie Garnier a également
un frère du nom de Antoine Garnier qui a
lui aussi une fille Lola Garnier cousine
de Justine et Hélène et héroïne de la
série le mied les abeilles en 92 qui n'a
pas eu de suite car l'actrice a montré
sa ch oh e ben [ __ ] avec tout ce
bordel s'il y en a pas au moins un dans
le tas qui a baisé sa cousine c'est un
exploit mais c'est pas fini parce que
parallèlement à ça on a eu une autre
série nommé Les Filles d'à côté et là
accrochez-vous nous entrons dans le
multiver alors dans le Lord de Abé il
existe un surlor elle c'est Lola du miel
et les abeilles elle est jouée par
l'actrice malorine Nataf mais quand elle
apparaît dans les filles d'un côté elle
ne joue pas Lola elle joue malorine natf
l'actrice qui joue dans le miel et les
abeilles qui est une série qui existe
dans le Lord des filles d' côté tu
connais mal natf bien sûr ah les
abeilles et vous vous êtes le miel oui
exactement mais tout est parfaitement
clair [ __ ] écoutez le mieux pour tout
comprendre c'est de repartir au
début ok alors peut-être pas aussi loin
quand même le plus vieux truc que je me
souviens dans ces séries c'est Salut les
Musclés j'étais super jeune alors salut
les Salut les Musclés donc c'était
l'histoire de C vieux trentenire
visiblement inapte à la vie en société
vraiment il lavabo dans leur salon qui a
un lavabo dans son salon le concept de
la série salulle musclé c'était simple
il y a une meuf qui arrive à un moment
dans leur maison pour x ou y raison et
ils essayent tous de la
baiser voilà c'est le concept est très
simple je vous l'ai dit tenez dans
l'épisode 1 la copine de framboisier
vient à la coloque alors l'appte est un
peu en ruine et il se trouve qu'elle est
un peu bricoleuse et tout le monde se
frotte dessus genre réy [ __ ] de
merde miné bordel mais tu fais quoi mais
c'est c'est quoi c'est un genre de
parade nuptiel les mriens là parce qu'
son est sur elle là on est d'accord hein
et [ __ ] mais c'est les pires coloes du
monde ouais écoutez les gars je vous
présente ma copine
bonjour et c'est à peu près la même
chose à chaque fois épisode 2 donc René
ramène une femme africaine trouvée dans
le métro qui visiblement ne sait pas
parler
d'ailleurs et qui évidemment possède les
mystérieux pouvoirs de l'Afrique j'ai
vous B de café mon Maître je vous café
cafarve je peux pas m'empêcher de penser
au moment où tu tournes une scène comme
ça et que le réalisateur
dit ok tout le monde en place pour la
scène avec les
chinois alors au passage je vais faire
une apparté chiante pour dire quelque
chose
d'évident je sais que comme ça ça a pas
forcément l'air d'être une bonne idée
évidemment quand quand on voit un
personnage comme ça
maintenant et que dans le même épisode
on enchaîne par ce personnage tout ce
que tu veux je te l'offre qui offre ses
épouses au musclés et que l'épisode
finit comme ça je crois que on sera pas
venu pour
[Applaudissements]
rien du coup s'ils arrivent à les
attrapper il se passe quoi bah la
merguesse partie je suppose c'est la
mergess mergess partie
bref donc en 2019 effectivement ça peut
un peu choquer mais il est indispensable
de se souvenir que c'est une série qui a
presque 30 ans les stéréotypes racistes
étaient très fréquents dans la série AB
et dans le club doroté en général je
veux dire il y avait rarement un clip de
doroté où elle finissait pas dans une
jungle de Cannibal au bout de quelques
minutes mé des CAN
et même quand la vidéo commencit au Pôle
Nord à la
base la fameuse frontière entre le Pôle
Nord et l'Afrique et pourtant c'est
important de rappeler qu'il y avait pas
de méchanceté gratuite derrière ces
stéréotypes c'était juste considéré
comme banal en fait tu en avait partout
que ce soit dans les déessais animés ou
dans la publicité et au final beaucoup
des choses sur lesquelles je plaisante
dans cet épisode à l'époque on m'aurait
juste répondu ouais et alors bref retour
au sujet donc parmi les personnages il y
avait franoisier le beau gosse il y
avait René le vieux il y avait Éric le
Toulousain il y avait réy le mec plutôt
normal il y avait miné le simpl du
groupe E les copains vous n'avez pas vu
mon nounours et il y avait la perche et
bien bonjour je suis Michel la perche
ravi de vous rencontrer la perche qui
est d'ailleurs un personnage à
partentière du monde de AB Production he
vu le nombre de fois où elle apparaît
c'est-à-dire absolument tous les [ __ ]
d'épisodes coucou coucou coucou coucou
coucou coucou y compris dans l'épisode 1
de Hélène et les garçons avant que le
premier personnage ne parle c'est la
perche qui apparaît oui le rythme était
infernal j'étais tout le temps là sur
tous les épisodes et puis pour un temps
d'apparition de moins d'une seconde bref
cinq personnages é héroclites mais tous
unis par une seule chose le harcèlement
et c'est pas que les meuf les mecs ils
ont tellement la dalle qu'il veulent se
taper aussi des extraterrestres dans
l'épisode 52 de Sal muscl apparî pour la
première fois le personnage de
extraterrestre venu de la planète Vega
pour rencontrer
framboisieris wou un étrange dialect
extraterrestre tu es sû moiutô c'est
l'autrichen de la planète autrichia bref
celleci ne parlant pas notre langue Ren
et min l'accueille et esse de comprendre
ce qu'elle dit de lui offrir un truc à
boire drink
[Musique]
boire il est quand même super mauvais he
pour mimer des trucs e tu tu veux te te
te laver les
mains enfin bref donc évidemment il
passe tout l'épisode à essayer de
l'emballer d'ailleurs je sais pas
pourquoi mais les extraterrestres c'est
quelque chose de super récurrent dans
les séries AB on avance de quelques
années dans la série Les Vacances de
l'amour une dessite de hè et les garçons
la série c'est du classique des épisodes
à base de petites intrigues amoureuses à
la plage quand
[Musique]
et ça
va vous croisez une femme évanouie dans
la forêt elle a l'air complètement
torchée réponse a vous l'emmenz au flic
réponse B vous l'emmenz au flic réponse
C mais emz-la au flic [ __ ]
personnellement ce que j'adore dans les
intrigues tordues dans les séries comme
ça c'est les réactions des personnages
il a jamais une réaction normale non
parce que je l'ai pas dit mais la meuf
qu'ils ont ramassé elle est visiblement
aussi poursuivie par deux autres
personnes qui sont aussi des
extraterrestres mais le problème c'est
que la série elle avait vraiment pas un
rond pour faire des
extraterrestres du coup on vous a mis
une petite musique
là c'est assez clair là c'est des
extrat heureusement qu'il y a de la
musique quand même en fait parce que là
si je change
[Musique]
truc ça pourrait aussi être des
touristes allemands enfin bref donc et
malgré tout ça il refuse d'appeler les
flics et Nicolas c'est pas normal cette
histoire fautf apper les flics tu veux
leur dire fille qu'on a trouvé une fille
dans la jungle qui parle jamais on sait
rien d'elle oui oui oui ça me semble pas
mal comme début oui après évidemment
c'est la nature de ces séries qui veut
ça tout est toujours arrangé de manière
à favoriser les situations gênantes et
les malentendues tenez après l'avoir
retrouvé donc plutôt que la police ou
l'hôpital il l'amène à leur hôtel pour
qu'elle prenne une douche parce que
c'était clairement ça l'urgence
visiblementendez mademoiselle mais
qu'est-ce que vous faites attendez mais
attendez moi sortir d'accord faut que je
sorte oh là non non mais mais madame
mais pourquoi vous
oh vous êtes
douché oh mon
dieu attention kproco il f droit sur
nous d'accord j'ai compris et en plus
dans notre champalie attends arrête
arrête arrte je t'en pr arrê fa
toutexliquer c'est pas du tout ce que tu
crois ah oui enfin laiss le s'expliquer
alors c'est une extraterrestre qui R et
personne n'en reparlera n'empêche j'ai
hâte de voir comment Justine va se
débrouiller au concours de maillot
organisé par
Michel sérieusement on va pas reparler
du fait qu'on aroisé des
extraterrestres et d'ailleurs vous
saviez que Damien craque aussi sur
Justine et Adeline n'est même pas au
courant on a la confirmation d'une vie
sur une autre planète et ils sont ici
donc alors on a eu des aliens dans
quasiment toutes les séries AB mais la
poogée des aliens ça sera quand même la
série extra zigda une série avec un
principe un petit peu pompé sur Marie
Poppins ou une extraterrestre venant du
futur on n pas le temps devient la
nourrice d'une familleente zigda la
jeune fille au père qui va habiter chez
nous salut super elle est canon et ne
vous inquiétez pas elle n'a pas été
recruté que pour son physique c'est
surtout une excellente actrice ah voyons
ce qu'il y a dans le réservoir de
nourriture génial des protéines
naturelles ça existe encore ici c'est
extraordinaire non mais je suis navré
mais entre la tête du mec le niveau
d'acteur de la fille le scénario où une
fille au père en tenue extra courte et
moulante vient garder les enfants d'un
homme visiblement célibataire et les
lignes de dialogue à double sens je ne
comprends rien à ce qu'il me raconte ce
que je pourrais bien faire pour l'aider
il y a vraiment beaucoup de scénarios
dans ce film porno mais c'est quand
qu'il baise après je me moque un peu de
son acting mais en réalité je devrais
pas parce que ils sont tous aussi
mauvais qu'elle en fait alors je dis pas
ça méchamant mais si je me souviens
aussi bien des séries AB c'est justement
pour le niveau des acteurs genre quand
j'avais 8 ans je me disais déjà que ces
gens jouaient très très mal c'est
terrible qu'un enfant se dis ça et le
fond du panier pour moi c'était la série
le collège des cœurs brisés je vous jure
que j'ai vu vu des enfants mieux jouer
dans des pièces de théâtre au CME
tous
[Musique]
tous la punition sera sera exemplaire
what the fuck et j'ai même pas
spécialement fouillé en plus j'ai juste
pris un extrait au hasard d'un épisode
au hasard et j'ai cherché des
renseignements les gens ne font pas
exprès de mal jouer c'est réellement
comme ça dans toute la
série oh mon dieu
je l'ai
[Musique]
tué
Mathilde
François Mathilde
François Mathilde ta gueule qui parle
comme ça en vrai Nathalie quoi Nathalie
mais quoi Nathalie mais quoi [ __ ] et
ces problèmes d'acting on les avait un
peu dans toutes les séries il faut
comprendre que les acteurs des séries AB
c'était au mieux des débutants au pire
pas des acteurs du tout genre Philippe
vassur ou José dans hlen et les garçons
à la base c'était juste le mec qui
faisait la déco et qui a été embauché
juste parce qu'il avait les chevelon et
qu'il était un peu beau gosse et on a
justement pas encore parlé de Hélène et
les garçons alors que c'était
certainement la série vitrine Hélène et
les garçons c'est donc une série qui
raconte les péripéties amoureuses d'une
bande d'étudiants en art à la fac et
comme tous les étudiants en art à la fac
ils ont beaucoup trop temps libre
passent leur vie à la cafette ouais
commencez pas à raller vous savez que
c'est vrai et comme pour toutes les
autres séries AB quand tu reçois le
script la veille et que tu dois jouer
genre
des émotions et ben c'est
compliqué
Hélène Natalie qu'est-ce qui se
passeinda vite Hélène elle a avé un tu
somnifère qu'est-ce que tu dis elleêtait
pas de me répéter absolument de dire
adieu avant de mourir waouh grandiose
superbe interprétation de l'ami qui fait
semblant d'être inquiète pour sa pote
bon après là je tire un peu sur
l'ambulance parce que l'actrice qui
jouit Natalie à l'époque elle était
réputée pour pas jouer très bien mais il
a raison de m'en vouloir
je sais pas ce qui m'a pris j'ai envie
de jouer à vous faire de mal le plus de
mal
possible je sais pas quand quand j'ai
commencé à à jouer avec Nicolas et à
faire toute cette comédie avec José je
sais pas je sais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas je suis désolé c'est
l'émotion snif mais il y a mieux épisode
208 un personnage du nom de Thomas est
en train d'annoncer à Hélène qu'il a le
sida ce qui est quand même une annonce
assez dramatique
voilà euh je suis cérroositif et j'en ai
plus pour très longtemps
ah non c'tait quoi ça ok c'est pas grave
hlen hein tu feras mieux la prochaine
fois heureusement qu'il s'est rien passé
entre toi et moi j'en ai parlé à
natthalie parce qu'elle en
revanche bah elle est en danger oh non
bon écoute je te monre des trucs et tu
réagis ok j'ai mangé le dernier Pépito
oh non madame votre feu arrière gauche
ne fonctionne pas attention non mention
spéciale au passage à l'acteur qui lui
aussi est exceptionnel dans le rôle du
mec qui annonce qu'il a le sida
malheureusement c'est à la mode en ce
moment j'ai toujours été à la mode belle
saloperie ce truc
là ça pourrit vraiment tout et voilà le
C PAF moi je te dis il y a des fois tu
as envie d'être couché r la bargoulette
r la maroulette un autre truc qui
m'avait marqué c'était les boîtes à rire
alors il y en a dans toutes les séries
on l'a vu tout à l'heure avec salut les
musclés mais genre il y en a vraiment
tout le temps Christian il se drog
quoiir ça tout de suite mais attends tu
sais bien qu'
droitier jele plus rien pareil pour les
jingles vous savez dans ces séries en
général à chaque changement de scène on
a droit petit jingle des fois faudrait
éviter quoi c'est pas une raison tu en
as pas bien profité peut-être he ok ch
ok je crois qu' vaut mieux que je m'en
aille d'accord
ok non
non reste ici
elle était cachée dans le grenier les
nazis sont rentrés ils ont tout
retourné
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
retrouver alors je sais qu'on en a parlé
plusut tôt dans Les Vacances de l'amour
mais niveau irresponsabilité des
personnages Hélen et les garçons étant
le préquel des Vacances de l'amour on
retrouve donc un petit peu la même chose
par exemple quand il y a quelqu'un qui
essaie de se suicider s'il vous plaît
aidez-moi Nathalie a fait une bêtise
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe elle avé un
tube de
somnifère leur première réaction c'est
toujours de prévenir les potes tu as
pensé à prévenir une ambulance une quoi
en fait je pense que la série se passe
dans un espèce de futur dystopique où
les services de l'État ont disparu
l'épisode d'après c'est encore pire il y
a une meuf donc il se fait harceler à la
cafette par un mec tu l' pas et là et
ben tu vas voir je vais te punir
moi lâche ça non non lâchez ça je vous
dis et maintenant partez qu'on vous
revoit plus vous avez compris
ouais bah c'est bon je crois qu'il a
compris
laissez-le comment ça laissez-le il a
compris il vient d'essayer de poignarder
quelqu'un
allez chou chou et ne recommence Pasin
sinon je vais briser tes e je vais boire
ton sang un autre truc qui me faisait
pas mal rire dans cette série c'était
les garçons et leur musique vous savez
les garçons dans hen et les garçons à
l'époque c'était l'équivalent des
groupes de capop maintenant les filles
ovulé rien qu'à la vue de Nicolas le
côté cheveux long musicien beau gosse et
pourtant tu ne les voyais jamais jouer à
un morceau en entier pourquoi parce que
les acteurs ne savaient pas jouer de
[Musique]
musique
mon premier clavier par Matel d'ailleurs
au final quand vous repensez àine et les
garçons maintenant beaucoup là vous
repensez à des petites intrigues
amoureuses machin et cetera mais non
c'était vachement plus trage que ça il y
avait des tentatives de suicide des
tentatives de viol collectif des gens
bourrés je n'ai rien je m'aime très bien
extrêmement bien et j'ai soif joué par
des gens qui n'ont jamais été bourrés
Nicolas c'est toi c'est marrant tu es
encore vivant j'ai pas d taper assez
fort pour te casser la tête le
jourir quoi Christian quoi
Christian Christian il est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mort merci les Mar de
TER devant et il y avait aussi les
fameux épisodes sur la drogue notamment
un épisode très célèbre qui a été
censuré en France où h mange des
spacecakes c'estàd des gâteaux cannabis
et rigole comme une conne pendant tout
l'épisode avec ses potes
drogués alors je n'ai jamais pris de
drogue mais pour moi ce type
là
il est pas drogué il est possédé par le
diable évidemment il y avait aussi des
scène de bagarre je vous avais déjà
montré la fameuse scène de baston de la
fin mais c'est minable mais quand on
fouille en fait il y en a
pleinous
AER
lâcheâ
lâ twist c'est parti les four ont
garanti avec twi bref les séries AB on
pourrait continuer à en parler pendant
des heures et au final je suis sûr qu'il
y aura un épisode 2 tant il y a de
choses à dire et d'ailleurs je remercie
énormément la chaîne génération sitcom
leur lien est dans la description qui
nous ont permis d'utiliser ces extraits
qui ont rendu cet épisode possible alors
évidemment je me moque un peu maintenant
parce que c'est devenu terriblement
kitch à regarder mais même si j'en étais
pas spectateur à l'époque j'ai quand
même une certaine tendresse pour ces
séries qui étaient souvent réalisé avec
les moyens du bord un peu à l'arrache
avec pas beaucoup d'argent dans la
production avec le script qui était
donné au dernier moment des acteurs pas
très concernés des gens qui jouaient mal
la perche qui tombait dans le champ
les merde mais c'est complètement nous
en
fait c'est toujours les
vacances au Club
JDG on a de la chance on est tous
abonnés du lundi au dimanche hiver comme
été é j les vacances au cl
JDG les je pouris que vous
préféré ils sont
icig et toutes les stars que vous
adorez vous pourrez les
[Musique]
voir
toujours ser t émion
préférée des millions de
Cain
num
[Musique]
numérod y